this is the best I think you're going to
like this remember in early 2016 we did
a 26 minute video this was our first
video that we did working with segment
producer Noah Ferguson it was a
long-form piece about so called
religious scholar Reza Aslan and the
title of the video is Reza Aslan cannot
be trusted it looked at a variety of
claims made by Reza Aslan the video did
well nearly 400,000 views and again the
video was done in January of 2016 on
Twitter
tons of people were tweeting for months
the video - Reza Aslan and as far as we
knew he hadn't watched it or at least he
didn't want to respond or mention the
video and at least once or twice people
responded a rather Reza Aslan responded
to people who tweeted him saying that he
wasn't going to comment on it we
actually have one example tweet of this
that I can show you where somebody had
tweeted the video - Reza Aslan and he
responded something like any expose by
someone I've never heard of questioning
my academic credentials not worth it
there was another tweet where he said
something like he doesn't respond to
home made videos or something like that
which is like well the video was made in
our studio but what what does it matter
if it's made in a house or in a
commercial office building what matters
is the claims in the videos that was
sort of a weird response and it doesn't
matter that he had never heard of you
because if dozens and dozens of people
are going to him asking him to respond
right that's a whole nother issue at
that absolutely so a couple days ago he
was doing a book tour or some kind of
publicity tour for his CNN show or maybe
I guess according to this picture it
looks like he was part of a
distinguished lecture series at the
University of Wisconsin in Madison and a
student named Benjamin chilla went to
the event and started asking Reza Aslan
about some of his claims about female
genital mutilation and other issues and
Reza Aslan ended the conversation by
saying you've been watching too much
David Pakman this is great okay so sit
back I think you're going to enjoy this
I got an email from Benjamin and he said
hello mr. Pakman reza aslan visited my
university campus uw-madison so I
decided to attend his lecture I spoke to
him personally at a book
after the lecture and questions some
claims he made during a CNN interview at
the end he told me that I've watched too
much David Pakman even after he claimed
on his Twitter that he wasn't going to
watch it so let's dig into the video
here's how it starts off with Benjamin
asking a question about his CNN
interview - Reza Aslan I just want a
quick ask about an interview you did for
CNN you stated that female genital
mutilation is a Central African problem
and not an Islamic problem I did it I'm
arolea Ptolemy okay well and didn't you
say there that in Indonesia women in
terms of status or 100% equal to men
nowhere in the world are women 100%
equal to men especially here in the
United States what I said was according
to the law women have the same rights
and religious Indonesia as men do just
like here in the United States but only
a [ __ ] would think that women and men
in the United States especially so this
goes on for a bit and then Reza Aslan
wraps it up by saying the following take
a look at this not an equal problem with
every religion it's a problem that is
very much geared towards a particular
which is what UNICEF itself said which
is where I quoted we've been watching a
little too much David Pakman on online
but I appreciate it
I like how Benjamin just says okay I
don't even know that I have much of a
commentary other than okay so clearly
he's aware of the video that we did
because only then would he know that we
were questioning with data some of what
he said about FGM I want to restate this
I know there's a lot of people in our
audience who or rather not people
necessarily in our audience but people
who have seen the particularly oh reza
aslan is referring to who seemed to
genuinely hate reza aslan
i don't really have a problem with the
guy as a person i know a lot of people
say he's clearly deliberately trying to
mislead and blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
my assumption about most people is
they're just going out there and telling
it as they see it and i may disagree
about the facts and that's where we
generate worthwhile discussions and I've
said it before I'll say it again
reza aslan is welcome on the show
anytime I think he probably doesn't want
to give us any attention so you know I
understand why he wouldn't be on I don't
I don't think that this is a genuinely
bad person or anything like that he
might prove me wrong right but but my my
thing with this entire reza aslan thing
has just been hey i've done research and
it seems like the facts are not as he
stated them and we should explore that
period and that was really the goal of
the video and this you know more than a
year later now this just is sort of a
funny bookend to the entire reza aslan
thing it seems like he's still sour
about the exchange that you two had over
a year ago at this point it wasn't
really an exchange though like we did a
video and he never really responded to
it okay well at any case i mean he would
be it would be great if he could come on
the show it will give his side of the
story anytime reza aslan is welcome on
the show